well for about 15 years now we've been
able to measure brain
with brain imaging through our machine
methods we've been able to interpret
what that hotspot of information is what
the underlying information is in the
various parts of the brain what we're
doing is trying to tie the biology of
the brain the neural activity to the
ideas that we're thinking about there
are total of eight distinct ones that
each one is going to be shown three
times and that'll be the data that we'll
be using and the only information that
won't have to go on is the brain image
so from his brain image for these things
we still have to identify which one it
is
now that we've collected the images from
Justin's brain while he was thinking
about these eight words we've asked the
computer algorithm to look at the brain
imaging data that we've collected and
tell us which word was which was my
first guest is chisel God chisel on the
first guess so in the next experiment
what we're doing is we're going to take
a classifier that was not trained using
data from Justin instead it was trained
using data from other people and we're
going to determine whether that
classifier which has never seen data
from Justin's brain before can
successfully determine which word that
he's looking at so the first word we've
asked it to say was the word eye or was
it closet I think the word is all right
okay so it was correct it got it this is
based entirely on other people's brain
activation I think the word is apartment
I think that it got on 10 out of 10 and
in a two choice test it got a perfect
score
now what this shows is that other people
represented these 10 items rather
similarly to the way that Justin did it
means that all of us to some extent when
we think of a chair or an apple or a
hammer or any physical object very
similar things are happening to her
brain that was never known before that's
a that's a result that was published for
the very first time 15 years ago we
didn't have the brain imaging technology
for doing this 15 years ago we didn't
have the machine learning technology for
doing this putting these together and
being able to really see capture the
data to see the patterns of activation
and then have the computational models
to make sense of them it's really a new
thing in the history of the study of
this question over centuries it's not an
accident that this occurred at Carnegie
Mellon we're not at a medical school but
we have the techniques the theories the
methods to get at brain function to
discover what it is to think like a
human being
to have ideas to generate new ones and
this science fiction kind of world is
just going to keep rolling forward and
we're gonna have new and better
knowledge about how our own minds work